el equipo de médicos de alexéi navalni
ha recurrido a twitter para arremeter
contra los funcionarios de las prisiones
rusas por impedirles ver a su paciente
estuvimos dos horas aquí todo el mundo
entiende que alexéi navalni está en un
estado grave y crítico
desafortunadamente no se nos permite
verlo sus doctores dicen que navalny
podría morir en cualquier momento ya que
los resultados de sus pruebas médicas
muestran que tiene insuficiencia renal y
los niveles de potasio peligrosamente
altos el servicio penitenciario trasladó
al opositor a un hospital para reclusos
actualmente el estado de salud de nava
ni se evalúa como satisfactorio es
examinado por un médico general todos
los días con el consentimiento del
paciente se prescribió una terapia
vitamínica navalny comenzó una huelga de
hambre hace tres semanas después de que
las autoridades penitenciarias se
negaron a permitirle ver a un médico
privado aseguran que estas imágenes que
lo muestran en un dormitorio de la
prisión en marzo sirven como prueba pero
éstas no pueden ser verificadas
independientemente naval ni fue
encarcelado en febrero tras regresar de
alemania donde fue tratado por un
envenenamiento del que culpa al kremlin
horas después de un discurso a la nación
del presidente putin los partidarios más
cercanos al opositor están convocando
protestas nacionales para el miércoles
pero desde el kremlin calificaron la
convocatoria como provocador a la
policía rusa advirtió que no se
permitirá ninguna desestabilización que
las protestas se considerarán ilegales y
que tomarán todas las medidas necesarias
para dispersarlas